personne n'a oublié ces images où l'on
voit des policiers à battre allait
magloire alors qu'il était un christ
d'un centre ville de montréal
le récemment il y a eu jimmy cloutier
devant l'émission oldbury et en juin
dernier c'était pierre coriolan pourtant
au fil des ans des coroners ont proposé
des solutions pour éviter qu'on ne se
retrouve avec de tels drames
c'est le cas du coroner luc malouin qui
avait fait toute une série de
recommandations en 2016
dans la foulée de la mort d'alain
magloire l'eau traitée mais aujourd'hui
cet ex directeur d'un centre de crise du
centre ville de montréal est déçu de ce
qu'il a vu certains policiers n'ont pas
compris que ça se fait plus arrêter de
faire sort c'est un conduit
pourtant au cours des dernières années
on améliorer la formation des policiers
en santé mentale temps à l'école
nationale de police qu'au service de
police de montréal comme le recommandait
le coroner malouin ici à montréal il y à
plus de 220 policiers qui ont été formés
pour intervenir dans ce genre de
situation il ya eu des progrès mais
définitivement y en a pas eu assez
donc il faut trouver d'autres façons de
d'améliorer l'intervention de la police
pour éviter de tels drames tous les
policiers devraient être capables
d'intervenir ce que moi j'entends je
vois c'est qu'on pas de plan de match et
halim là ils paniquent et hopper qui
interviennent un peu comme à la méthode
américaine
dans son rapport le coroner malouin
recommandait aussi d'augmenter le nombre
de pistolets à impulsion électrique une
arme controversée
ce qui a été fait par le service de
police de montréal qui en a acheté une
cinquantaine l'an dernier j'aime mieux
voir des policiers utilisés le teaser
quelle arme à feu dans le dossier du
décès de pierre coriolan c'est encore
une fois le coroner luc malouin qui
enquêtent
il devrait remettre son rapport au cours
des prochains mois il sera donc
intéressant de voir quels seront ses
recommandations ici jean philippe robien
à radio canada montréal